We gotta get to this next thing because it has been burning up our heat index.
The zesty guy we've been showing you all morning,...
...he's gone viral.
You ask why?
Well, keep watching.
Undressing to sell salad dressing, ABC's Linsey Davis is here with that.
Tough assignment, Linsey.
It is tough stuff. Good morning, Amy.
Kraft, the Midwestern-based company known for being conservative in its advertising is going sexy.
The new ad campaign is the sexiest, or should I say 'zestiest', they've ever gone...
...as they experiment with a new way to sell salad dressing to women.
Ladies, let's make a salad, shall we?
This is the most beautiful pepper I've ever held.
How zesty do you want it?
You've probably never thought of salad dressing as hot, sizzling or spicy.
But Kraft is pouring it on thick.
How about a lot more?
With an ultimately shirtless hunk of a chef.
A little more.
This guy, Anderson Davis, is the one people are talking about.
It's really nice to have people come up and say, "Dude, you're super zesty."
Whatever they're gonna say to you.